the president will travel to greensboro
north carolina where he will visit north
carolina agricultural and technical
state university for a tour of their new
harold l martin senior engineering
research and innovation complex which
opened in february
north carolina ata and a and t is the
largest historically black college and
university in the nation and the largest
producer of african american
undergraduates
in engineering and with master's degrees
in mathematics statistics in engineering
in the country
ncant is also the alma mater of epa
administrator michael
regan and two of the president's recent
appointees to his board of advisors on
hbcus since january of 2021 president
biden and members of his cabinet have
prioritized visits to hbcu campuses
across the nation and the biden harris
administration has invested an
unprecedented 5.8 billion dollars in
these critical institutions with more to
come this year the president will meet
faculty and students who are studying
robotics and cyber security and i'll
talk about how investments in the
bipartisan innovation act can help build
on the remarkable progress we've made
over the last year in getting our
economy back on its feet through the
american rescue plan and in laying a
foundation for an economic renewal
that's made in america through the
bipartisan infrastructure law throughout
his visit the president will highlight
the domestic manufacturing strategy and
regional investments in areas such as
advanced manufacturing and clean
technology he will discuss how
greensboro's economy and educational
institutions are reinventing themselves
for legacy industries to 21st century
industries and will benefit from the
package of the bipartisan innovation act
which will make historic investments in
r d innovation and manufacturing in
america that means stronger supply
chains more manufacturing jobs and lower
prices for consumers as we break up the
bottlenecks like semiconductor chips
that have driven inflation over the last
year 473 000 manufacturing jobs have
already been created on the president's
watch he wants to build on that success
by passing the bipartisan innovation act
to create
to create more good paying jobs and
lower prices for working families also
wanted to note that today during black
maternal health week vice president
kamal harris will convene a first ever
white house meeting with cabinet
secretaries and agency leaders to
discuss the administration's whole of
government approach to reducing maternal
mortality and morbidity in december of
2021 vice president harris announced a
historic call to action to improve
health outcomes for parents and their
young children in the united states
today the administration is making
additional announcements as part of our
continued response to that call to
action the announcements include 11
states and the district of columbia
working with center the centers for
medicare and medicaid services to expand
medicaid coverage through the american
rescue plan from 2 months to 12 months
following a pregnancy
cms's birthing friendly
hospital designation which would assist
families in choosing hospitals that have
demonstrated a commitment to maternal
health will all will go live with
initial quality measures in the fall of
2022 final piece and then we'll get to
your questions uh since before taking
office the president and his team has
have made finding highly qualified
judicial nominees who are devoted to the
rule of law and our constitution and who
ensure that the federal bench more fully
represents our country a critical
priority last week you all saw the
senate's bipartisan history making
confirmation of soon-to-be justice
kentaji brown jackson a judge with the
strongest credentials imaginable with
the backing of law enforcement and many
of the most respected retired
conservative jurists in the country and
earn some of the strongest public
support of any supreme court nominee in
recent american history tying chief
justice roberts during his confirmation
this morning the president announced his
first round of judicial nominees since
judge jackson's confirmation bringing
the total number of nominees he has put
forward including
judge jackson to 90. a number of these
picks if confirmed would also make
history for example judge john lee would
be the first asian-american judge to
ever serve on the seventh circuit of
appeals and nancy maldonado would be the
first hispanic woman to serve as a
federal judge in illinois the president
is very proud of all the nominees he has
announced in office 72 of whom are women
30 percent of whom are black 21 percent
of whom are hispanic and 19 percent of
whom are from the aapi pi community with
that let's get to your questions i'll
promise to reduce the toppers next time
that's my deal go ahead
thanks uh
on the president uh calling what's going
on in ukraine's genocide
what changed what did the president see
what did he hear um in the days uh
between saying maybe we're simply war
crimes
well he called it a genocide yesterday
not once but twice actually because as
he said yesterday it's becoming clear
and clear each day that it is putin's
aim to wipe out the idea of being
ukrainian that we're seeing greater
brutality increase day by day and some
of that i will note is because
we're seeing we're gaining greater
access to areas we have more
intelligence on what's happening in
areas leaders are speaking out more
about and frankly there's also reporting
about what is happening on the ground
but to give you some specifics i would
note that of course
what we saw in bucha was not an anomaly
as ukrainian forces search towns that
russian forces previously occupied as
they're pulling back and moving to the
east the mayor and the city council of
mariopol are reporting high numbers of
civilian casualties the train station
attack just over the weekend killed more
than 50 civilians the un has recently
reported recorded 4 450 civilian
casualties all just since february 24th
and the real number we believe is likely
much higher the osce's moscow mechanism
report today found clear patterns of
international humanitarian law
violations by russian forces by
targeting hospitals schools residential
buildings and other locations where
civilians are sheltering and we've also
seen i think from the beginning of this
kremlin rhetoric and russian media deny
the national identity of the ukrainian
people and the kremlin has launched a
full-scale assault on the sovereignty of
the ukrainian state and its people so
the president was speaking to
what we all see what he feels is clear
as day in terms of the atrocities
happening on the ground as he also noted
yesterday of course there will be a
legal process that plays out in the
courtroom but he was speaking to what he
has seen on the ground what we've all
seen in terms of the atrocities on the
ground
and uh follow-up might be calling
germany to impose a natural gas ban
given that given what he said
well we've been in ongoing discussions
with our european partners including
germany but it is a decision uh they
will make uh and the president certainly
supports their right to do exactly that
go ahead
a question about the president's
conversation today with president
zielenski
did they talk about the possibility of
moving u.s diplomats back into ukraine
uh i don't have more details of that i
will tell you that our objective is to
do exactly that and we of course assess
in a process that's led by the state
department security considerations who
the right personnel to go back first
would be and that's certainly something
the president would like to see but i'm
not aware of him providing an update on
that today also president
tweeted that he and the president
president biden agreed to quote enhanced
sanctions what does that mean additional
sanctions the consideration of
additional sanctions and that's
certainly something we're continuing to
consider and the president conveyed that
as well
and then back to the question about
genocide last week jake sullivan was
here at this podium he said we have not
yet seen a level of systematic
deprivation of life of the ukrainian
people to rise to the level of genocide
so is it now the white house position
that you have actually seen a level of
systematic deprivation that would
qualify as jesus the president spoke to
that twice yesterday and of course he's
the president and we are here to uh to
implement his views and then finally um
has the u.s or any non-governmental
partner had any ability to
assess
with any greater certainty that any kind
of chemical or nerve agent was actually
used in mariupol we don't have any
update on that at this point in time
go ahead thank you jen uh following up
on nancy's question did anyone know that
the president was going to use the word
genocide in his remarks it seemed like a
passing
uh remark or passing reference in a
broader conversation about inflation
well it's he's the president of the
united states and the leader of the free
world and he is allowed to make his
views known at any point he would like
it was not scripted that wasn't
pre-planned again i think we shouldn't
misunderstand who he is and where he
stands in the totem pole which is at the
top
and then on the call today can you
clarify one other thing there has been
some reporting that the helicopters were
not going to be part of the package and
then they went back into the package can
you clarify if the call with zelinski
was the
uh
item was the thing that put those
helicopters back in the package so so on
this i know there's been some different
reporting and confusion so i appreciate
you asking uh we are of course in
constant conversations with ukrainians
as is evidenced by this morning and the
two i recall that chairman millie and
jake sullivan had last week and what
they need and how we can be helpful it
was unclear for a while um from their
side whether they wanted additional
helicopters we've provided them
helicopters in the past uh and today
they made clear they wanted them in so
we said great they're helicopters in the
package
the first bus of migrants arrived in d.c
today uh texas governor greg abbott
making good on his promise to send
migrants to the president's doorstep
uh
i think you previously called it a
publicity stunt is that still the view
of the white house can you give us any
reaction to
this busload of migrants arriving here
in dc well these are all migrants who
have been processed by cbp and are free
to travel so it's nice the state of
texas is helping them get to their final
destination as they await in their their
outcome of their immigration proceedings
and they're all in immigration
proceedings and then on your statement
this morning um you had mentioned in in
that statement that the truck
inspections
uh have led that governor abbott has
been conducting have led to disruptions
for the food and automobile supply
chains and rising prices for families so
is the white house blaming greg abbott
for inflation
well i think we're trying to state the
facts of what his another political
stunt that we're seeing happen and the
impact of it um and what we're seeing is
right now factually there's over one
million dollars in trade crossing over
the u.s mexico border every minute these
actions are impacting people's jobs and
the livelihoods of hard-working families
in texas and across the country that's
not a political statement that's a
statement of fact i'd also note that
what we're seeing with these unnecessary
inspections of trucks trans
transiting ports of entry between texas
and mexico are significant delays which
are resulting in a drop in commercial
traffic of up to 60 to 70 percent in
some ports and that is significantly
impacting the local and regional supply
chains the point that trade associations
officials and businesses are calling for
the texas governor to reverse their self
this self-inflicted gridlock i'd also
note that cbp officers are very good at
their jobs and texas dps does not need
to replace cbp at the southern border
cbp has conducted a record number of
drug seizures with more than 900 000
pounds of narcotics seized just in fy
2021 so the economic impact here
something that people of all political
stripes are calling for a reversal of is
something that we think is significant
and we felt should be shouted out last
one does the white house still view
inflation as transitory
that is the view of the uh federal
reserve and outside economists and they
all continue to project it will come
down this year
yeah um just to make sure we're clear
first of all in the question of genocide
because i know sometimes in the past the
president's expressed his own opinion
about issues it's not necessarily been
u.s policy so is it the u.s policy that
genocide is being committed in ukraine
or was that the president's personal
beliefs well there is a legal process as
the president said yesterday that will
be
we'll go we'll be undergone and will
happen um and he wasn't getting ahead of
that he was speaking to what we feel he
feels we see on the ground but
regardless of what you call it what our
objective now as evidenced by the
enormous package of military assistance
we put out today is continue to help and
assist the ukrainians in this war and
one where we see atrocities happening
every single day is there any concern
though that
the president's views on things
differing from what the actual policy is
once it's gone through all those legal
channels but that could be confusing to
world leaders when the president's one
saying one thing that the policy isn't
necessarily how would it impact the
outcome yeah well i mean
once there's a genocide being committed
in a region other countries would treat
that in a certain way if that's in what
way
i guess as far as how the way leaders
would try you know decide how they're
going to respond to that
so
typically a consideration of genocide
takes years i mean look at uh there are
many past examples and if you look at
even uyghurs right and what we've uh
called out happening in china that took
many years to call out that hasn't meant
we've provided a range of military
assistance what we are doing now is
we're trying to prop up and support
ukrainian leaders there are other and in
the military of course there are other
leaders who have in the world who have
said something similar to what the
president has said recently because
they're also seeing the atrocities on
the ground i don't i don't know that
it's changed policy or confused anyone i
think they're speaking all from uh what
they are seeing with their own eyes as
we look at the visuals of what's
happening on the ground so you don't see
kids in there and then just a quick
follow-up from a topic from last week
following the president's exposure to
house speaker pelosi did he ever receive
any
post-exposure prophylaxis like
monoclonal antibodies which are approved
from the fda in certain circumstances
for people who've been exposed if you're
immunocompromised immunocompromised
female thyroid yeah he's not
immunocompromised so no okay so he does
not receive any any treatment he's not
immuno compromised okay go ahead
thank you jen earlier today treasury
secretary janet yellen said countries
that are currently sitting on the fence
amid russia's abbreviation of ukraine
risk facing isolation from the global
economy
were those comments aimed at any
specific countries and can you speak to
whether the administration is
considering secondary sanctions on
countries that do not comply with the
restrictions the administration has
imposed on russia thus far well i think
certainly we consider a range of options
if countries don't abide by the
sanctions we've implemented right and
that is something we certainly will
continue to watch uh i don't have any
projections of that fortunately at this
point in time i think she was speaking
to what we've said from here a number of
times which is that in this moment where
you have a dictator brutally invading
another country targeting civilians you
have to contemplate what side of history
you want to be on and that is true for
any country around the world
is the administration concerned
that coba data is not picking up many
cases that are confirmed by home tests
especially amid this uptake caused by
the ba2 variant and will there be a
public education campaign to push people
to report their positive results well we
do certainly encourage people uh in many
ways to uh to share test results and
contact their doctor uh because they may
be eligible for pex livid or other
therapeutics if they test positive we
also know that um that a number of
people who test positive are at home
just recovering at home so we're
certainly encouraging people to do that
but what i would note is that what the
cdc continues to track very closely are
cases that are uh reported in the where
they've seen
severe disease hospitalizations and
deaths and those reports are coming
directly from hospitals and states and
what we're seeing from those reports are
the lowest levels of hospitalization
since the start of the pandemic so we
certainly encourage people to report
anyone who lives in this area knows
there if you have apps on your phone you
often get apps about or alerts about
closed contacts or if you've been near
people or calls from you know your
county health uh health uh people if
there are reports in your neighborhood
we encourage people to do that but our
focus as the cdc has conveyed uh over
the course of last weeks is really on
severe disease hospitalizations and
deaths what we can do to reduce those
we're fortunately seeing lower numbers
even as we've seen an uptick in cases
thanks um i spoke to former nfc chairman
robert o'brien on friday he says most
republicans and most if not all
democrats are on board with the current
russian sanctions however he had two
criticisms he said that one plane should
be provided to
uh ukraine and two that full sanctions
should be implemented against russia and
putin immediately uh your thoughts and a
response to that i don't have a direct
response to robert o'brien what i can
tell you or and i'm sure he's aware of
this or maybe not i don't know that we
have uh we have implemented a more
significant and crippling sanctions
package financial sanctions package than
has ever been done on any large economy
in history uh so i would i would
certainly point to that uh in terms of
his view uh as a private citizen i guess
at this point on planes that we've
spoken to that in the past if other
countries want to provide planes we're
not standing in the way we've made an
assessment about what the ukrainian
military
needs uh and what they are trained on to
use and what would be effective in uh in
the transport of it that continues to be
our assessment i noticed that the
helicopters were on the table are uh u.s
warplanes provided to ukraine or even
the mix from warsaw from poland are they
off the table we've never said they were
off the table what we've said is that we
had concerns about the polish proposal
about how they would be transported and
our military made an assessment about
that a risk assessment about the
benefits and the risk that assessment
hasn't changed we've provided
helicopters in the past around that is
there i don't have any more updates for
you go ahead one more question on
ukraine after president biden said he
does believe that russia is committing
dennis that the french president came
out and said that he warned against an
escalation of rhetoric do you have any
response to macron i don't
uh on covet and this extension this
two-week extension of masking on public
transportation can you help us
understand some of the science behind
this why two weeks uh sure what
difference can be made in such a short
amount of time sure well this um
assessment was made i know there was a
statement that was put out by the cdc
and certainly would point to that but as
they're continuing to monitor the spread
of of ba2 the ba2 subvariant which now
makes up more than 85 percent of u.s
cases what they're looking at is that
since early april there's been an
increases in the seven day moving
average of the cases in the united
states so what they're trying to do is
give a little bit more time to assess
its potential impact the rise of the
cases have on severe disease including
hospitalizations and deaths and the
healthcare system capacity and their
assessment from a medical standpoint the
data data gathering standpoint is that
two weeks would give them some
additional time to do that now at the
end of that two weeks they can determine
what's next after that but um but that
is a that assessment they made so that
they could gather more data of the rise
of the sub-variant we've been expecting
should the public expect sort or more of
these kind of short-term extensions it's
a good question i just don't want to
make a prediction of that i think it
depends on how they evaluate and assess
the the um the data over the course of
the next two weeks and they're trying to
provide regular transparent updates to
the public and it does seem the
president has been tested every two or
three days for the past week or so any
update on whether he was tested today
uh i can check and see if there's an
update and get that to all of you um he
does have a regular testing cadence of
course that is determined by his doctor
and it's typically a couple times a week
go ahead thank you a quick follow-up on
the issue of the genocide designation i
think you just said that a legal process
would be undergone but i think the state
department spokesman price just said
that it was the us government is
contributing to the ukrainian prosecutor
general's office's inquiry into whether
uh russia has committed genocide in
ukraine but had not initiated its own so
i appreciate your opportunity to
rephrase it would require a legal
process as the president said yesterday
he's not trying to pre-judge a legal
process he was speaking to the
atrocities he saw on the ground why not
why would the u.s initiate its own you
know inquiry into that issue it's a
determination again made by the state
department and others who are
lead these efforts
and certainly
it's one we will continue to assess
and just a quick one on the issue with
greg abbott is the white house planning
to do anything to alleviate the supply
chain disruptions or pressure him into
rescinding the order
well obviously our preference is that he
rescinds the order and it's not just our
preference it's the preference of a
number of trade associations officials
business leaders and others who are
seeing a direct impact on commerce and
on the economy and on business in the
community so uh beyond that i think our
effort today was to highlight what the
impact is and how
this is not a step that is uh that is an
immigration policy or addressing uh root
issues at the border this is one that is
hurting uh has having a negative
economic impact on people who work and
live uh in that community and uh the
over one million dollars in trade
crossing over the border every day but
jen three times now the president has
made comments about the war that the
white house or he himself subsequently
said did not reflect u.s policy or legal
determination when he said putin is a
war criminal when he said that putin
cannot remain in power and of course
this comment about this being genociding
ukraine um does this not send a signal
to the world that there kind of is an
asterisk uh any next to anything that
the president says well then when the
president ran uh he promised the
american people he would uh shoot from
the shoulder as his phrase that he often
uses and tell to them straight and his
comments yesterday not once but twice
and on war crimes are are an exact
reflection of that uh i don't think
anybody is confused about the atrocities
of what we're seeing on the ground the
horrors of what we're seeing in the
grounds and different leaders around the
world describe it in different ways but
what where there is what is
unquestionable is what we're seeing is
horrific the targeting of civilians of
hospitals of of of even kids um and um
and it the president was calling it like
he see uh he like he sees it and that's
what he does if i could ask it this way
do you think that there is any danger to
global leaders including vladimir putin
uh to olef schultz if they can't be sure
when they hear words coming out of the
president's mouth whether he is stating
a personal opinion versus making a
statement about u.s policy do you have
an example of somebody who's confused
a leader
well i think my colleague brought up
emmanuel macron saying responding and
saying you know
the use of the language genocide he sees
as a rhetorical escalation
president putin is brutally targeting
civilians and brutalizing a country
right now so the president this
president was speaking uh to what those
atrocities are and what he is seeing on
the ground a number of other leaders
have done exactly that it does not
change policy in the sense that we've
seen these atrocities unfortunately for
weeks now and we're going to see more as
russia pulls back from parts of the
country so what our focus will continue
to be and the focus of leaders around
the world is to continue to escalate our
military assistance our security
assistance as we did today in providing
a range of uh of weapons that we have
not even provided to them in the past
and that i think is what the ukrainians
are most focused on and i think the
global community is most focused on how
we're responding and how we're helping
them could you explain so if the us were
to legally determine that what is
happening in ukraine is genocide what
would the sort of legal obligations from
the united states be at that point it
doesn't change a policy there would be
an international effort to
explore that and an investigation at an
international level those often take
many years
and
nothing has changed in terms of the
president
not wanting to send in u.s troops to
ukraine correct nothing has changed go
ahead thank you so much jen um two
questions one on um uh policing and
grand rapids michigan police just
released the tape of a
individual who was shot and killed by
police i understand it's happened while
you're on the podium you have not seen
it yet but i wanted to see if you um
believe the president will watch that
and the naacp is now calling on the
president to sign the policing executive
order is there any update that you can
provide about that well on the last
piece the president absolutely wants to
do exactly that and it has to go through
it it just takes some time to go through
a process but his intention is
absolutely to sign a policing executive
order into in into law or not into law
but sign it with his authorities um i
would note that what we have tried to do
from this administration even well there
was a stall in um in bipartisan action
in the senate is to take actions we can
with the authorities we have like the
department of justice banning chokeholds
or other steps they've taken with the
authority they have to address it at the
federal level i've not seen the video
thank you for prefacing that i've not
seen it yet i don't have a prediction of
if the president will watch it i assume
it is something that will be covered uh
on television and i can check and see if
there's an update for you and then i
just had to follow up to mj's question
sure when you're talking about the
president sort of
you know and i should practice this by
saying the you know the world and we are
all still getting to know this president
he has been around for a while but we
have not seen him in the role as
president
for a while um and so
can you tell us when should we
interpret his words as
his reaction versus u.s policy
he's the president of the united states
he speaks for the united states there's
also a legal review and process that is
important to take place uh in the case
of genocide or war crimes so we're
trying to provide as much information on
that as possible
that you can provide or any sort of you
know
any
giveaway is that this is the president
talking about what he's seeing and hit
his reaction as a human versus you know
the united states government is now
going to do x y and z because i have
determined i think what's important to
understand is that determination or
whatever you label it doesn't change
policy it change what we are doing right
now in terms of the amount of security
assistance we're providing including the
new package today goes far beyond what
we have done in many cases where there
ha we have called it genocide so there
is not a direct trigger in that way
and if that's helpful clarity for
anybody happy to provide it but he is
the president he speaks for what our
policy is and i would take his words for
exactly what they are go ahead
today
ukraine's president zoland said after
the call that they agreed to quote
enhance sanctions that's something that
did not come up thus far from you
can you give us any guidance on what
those enhanced sanctions mean what does
that mean sure so someone may have asked
this earlier which is of course fine um
what he was referring to and the
president agreed yes we're continuing to
consider a range of sanctions a range of
ways to hold president putin his circle
the uh the economy you know the the
financial sector accountable there will
be more to come but that was part of
their discussion today
specifically not today no they just had
the discussion there wasn't a new
announcement today is there has there
been any
we haven't taken anything off the table
as you know but i don't have any update
on that at this point in time go ahead
thanks uh just one on texas
right before you came out governor
abbott announced that they're halting
some inspections on that side of the
border and instead there'll be some
inspections conducted in nuevo flew
right of the mexican state of the border
of texas i don't know if you had seen
that or want to have a chance to respond
to it not yet and i don't have an
assessment on the impact but i think the
overarching view from not just us but
again trade associations officials and
businesses is that these are unnecessary
inspections and that they are impacting
the economy i don't i don't know how to
i can't gauge from here what the
economic impact will be but i'm happy to
take a look at that or have i can have a
team take a look at that sure uh go
ahead patrick thank you jen uh so i'm
gonna try again on the g20 uh president
biden has indicated that he wants uh
russia to not participate in g20 we know
that uh we also know that he said that
the forum cannot be business as usual
however i'm hearing from uh g20
diplomatic sources that they feel that
it's unfair to have the issue of ukraine
really overtake the forum which has an
economic mandate and it does have
economic goals including pandemic
recovery sustainable economic
development and so on so my question is
is the u.s still willing to work with
g20 partners to ensure that these goals
are met and that the summit is salvaged
well the summit is in seven months am i
correct yes okay so that's a lifetime it
takes a lot of months for it that is a
lifetime in diplomacy though i will say
and it is not uncommon for events that
are impacting the global community as
ukraine is and the russian invasion of
ukraine to play a central role at
international forum and their economic
recovery and rebuilding and
reconstruction is going to be something
that the global community is going to be
involved in and address but i don't the
agenda has not been set uh i don't i
don't think we know at this point how
dominant ukraine will be or not be it
depends i'm sure on where things stand
at that point in the world well the
agenda hasn't been set but the
presidency has already set these three
main pillars and they have nothing to do
with ukraine or russia so uh i guess
what would be the administration's
response to these criticism that say
inviting sorry disinviting russia or
including ukraine as an observer really
just disrupts the summit's agenda as
well as divide or create a rift among
members i think i would say that russia
and president putin have shown himself
and themselves to be a pariah in the
world and the president's view is that
he has no place at international forum
the inclusion of ukraine does not mean
it's only about the battle on the ground
we're going to need to rebuild ukraine
ukraine uh is a is it has just applied
for eu membership i'm not i can't
determine for you what that will look
like in the final stages but there's a
lot of topics that can be discussed and
russia's actions and president putin's
actions make them a country and a leader
that the president does not feel should
participate in an international fora one
question on china uh so u.s trade
representative ambassador thai
said in a recent interview that in the
long term the china trade challenge will
actually eclipse the crisis in russia
today so is the administration concerned
that the war in ukraine takes away your
focus uh and resources to meet the
challenges from china
we're not i mean how the us government
is set up as as you know is that we have
experts and
in every area right working
simultaneously at the same time yes the
war in ukraine is a big issue that we're
very focused on this president is very
focused on there's an entire team
focused on asia at the state department
the defense department the national
security team every single day that is
not involved
in that war so i would can assure you
and assure everybody that we are able to
walk chew gum and do multiple layers of
diplomacy at the same time
on the general side of the gps direction
i appreciate it is it it's okay i need
directions everywhere so i appreciate it
go ahead
again
you know european diplomats officials we
are talking to are saying this
escalation of words has an impact
because
because it makes the prospect of future
peace talks with vladimir putin very
difficult
or impossible so is the present by using
such words conveying the idea that there
will never be any possible talks with
putin and that the only way the walk can
end is is you know ministry capitulation
no and i would just dispute that
argument or that notion um peace talks
is something we're always going to
support the president secretary of state
our national security advisor are always
going to support and we support the
ukrainians in that effort
i think it's unlikely that uh that
president putin is moved is is going to
decide not to participate in peace talks
because of some words that came out of
the mouth of the president of the united
states he's going to decide to
participate them if it's in his
interests
the producer price index on inflation
came out at the highest level that
they've had in the history of recording
these
events this is the price that companies
are paying for the materials that they
need to make the stuff that they sell
right so with the last two days the
inflation reports um does the white
house believe that inflation has now
peaked and we're coming back down or
because of these reports do you think
we're going to see even worse numbers in
the future
we'll let the federal reserve uh make
projections about that they have the
preview uh over those projections uh
what i will say is that while we when we
talked about this over the last couple
days as it relates to the cpi data
consumer price index as opposed to
producer price index for others um and
what we saw well energy accounted for 70
of the monthly inflation in march on cpi
data accounted for a substantial portion
of ppi inflation as well and ppi
measures things like the cost of wood
metal plastics kind of materials like
that so it's not necessarily it's not a
surprise to us that energy is having an
impact is a driver of these numbers
obviously what we're trying to do is
mitigate the the energy impact and take
steps to do exactly that release from
the strategic petroleum reserve and
other actions working to get more supply
out into the marketplace but you know
again projections of
of a when we're hitting a height and and
where it will look we will leave that to
the federal reserve
so does the president then acknowledge
any responsibility for the inflation
that we're seeing now based on the
decisions that he's made when he came
into office
well i would say as the president has
talked about quite a bit there are a
range of factors including uh the
pandemic the impact on the supply chains
and our effort and what we've tried to
do from the beginning is take steps to
address that address the supply chains
and we've had a lot of success moving
more equipment and goods through through
through ports etc we've also seen given
energy is such an a significant driver
of this data an increase in energy
prices over the last month plus since
the invasion of ukraine that's factual
that's based on data that we have seen
out there so our effort and our focus
has been to try to address it and take
mitigation measures when we can take
responsibility for his decisions like
some say the american rescue plan
boosted demand uh when it didn't need to
larry summers was one of those well the
alternative would have been uh that we
would have gone into a massive economic
downward spiral and many americans would
have not had enough food to put on the
table so we chose the other path
go ahead thanks jen
senator schumer at a virtual event on
student debt today said
that he's talked personally to the
president uh quote a whole bunch of
times
and uh talking about canceling student
debt he said we're making progress folks
we are making progress the white house
seems more open to it than ever before
um has the president had conversations
with senator schumer and is he
you know moving
on this issue where he's more open to
the idea of the president's always been
happy to sign a bill into law passed by
congress that would cancel ten thousand
dollars in student debt uh there hasn't
been any decision made about other
executive actions has he shifted at all
his thinking is he you know
open to
he's always been happy to sign a law
into into a bill into a law that
canceled student debt that hasn't
changed good thank you thank you jen
the whole world against the russian
aggression in ukraine other than the few
countries
uh
free countries like bangladesh
bangladesh
prime minister recently told in the
parliament those though this parliament
is not mandated by the people she she
told that
that russia stood by us and our bad time
and we are surely
beside the country beside the russia and
she blamed usa not to help during the
liberation war in 1971. so what is your
comment about this authoritarian prime
minister sri maxi the parliament
i don't have any specific specific
response to to the prime minister i
would just say that what we're doing is
encouraging every country to uh think
hard about what side they're going to be
on history thanks jen um there was a new
pull out today that shows the
president's approval rating is still in
the low 40s and that voters are still
concerned about the economy is the white
house seen as a sign that their message
on the increased job numbers and all the
infrastructure funding isn't getting
through i mean the president has said he
wants to see his accomplishments being
sold is he satisfied that's being done
or is there talk about pivoted messaging
well i would say we understand some
realities happening right now including
the fact that there is a war happening
in europe and that is uh dominating the
airwaves which we understand and fully
expect and so uh the president has
actually done a number of events on the
economy in recent days and weeks
and will continue to but our view is
well the world needs to understand and
see how he is he is leading on the war
we also the world also needs here the
country needs to say i guess i should
say uh how he is continuing to lead on
the economy and i don't know that that's
a shift or requiring a shift it's just a
recognition that uh being able to
continue to speak to domestic or
domestic audience about that is a huge
priority and his schedule tells the
story of how much of a priority is
james hey yeah i wanted to ask about the
migrants that arrived today from texas
uh these are venezuelan and nicaraguan
migrants who have applied for asylum in
the us
has the administration been in touch
with these migrants or with the
organizations that are assisting them
such as catholic charities
the the uh migrants who are have
traveled on the bus from from texas well
they're all in immigration proceedings
um those who traveled on the bus and so
certainly that would mean they're in
touch with the appropriate entities in
the federal government about that
process but beyond that i don't have any
other updates nothing to that you have
not been in touch with them to make sure
that their rights are respected
well that
certainly is of vital importance to us
and as we've stated many times from here
nobody can forcibly be put on a bus they
would have to voluntarily be put on the
bus and if there are concerns about that
we would expect they would contact
appropriate authorities even if this
migrants wanted to get out of texas but
do you find it troubling that the texas
government governor used them as props
to make a political point uh to the
white house do you worry that this might
reinforce the narrative that
profiles undocumented people as criminal
uh criminals or bad people
well i said called it the other day a
publicity stunt um by governor abbott
and made clear that
immigration policy and law is overseen
by the federal government not state
governments so i think i spoke to that
the other day pretty clearly go ahead um
thank you john um since you mentioned a
team focusing on asia earlier i have
several asian questions
there have been reports out of japan
that the u.s uk and australia have
informally asked japan to become part of
caucus in the areas of emerging and
disruptive technologies but yesterday
the pentagon said they could not confirm
this and also the japanese government
itself has also now denied using this
news uh but can you just put this
potential jacques or office plus james
that's quite a name
i'm not sure about that
yes uh so i can uh the reporting is
inaccurate or the an original reporting
i should say is inaccurate as you noted
the chief cabinet secretary of japan has
himself said it's not true
and our focus has been on finalizing a
trilateral program of work on a range of
advanced military capabilities that
align our priorities amplify our
collective strengths and accelerate the
development and acquisition of
leading-edge defense capabilities but it
is not uh a jaukas plan
and another japan question if i may yeah
um yesterday uh some japanese media
outlets reported that arrangements were
underway for quad summit on may 24th
just as uh president biden had eluded on
monday
and that there were plans being made for
a bilateral with prime minister tashida
the day before on may 23rd is there any
part of a president-widens travel
schedule that you can confirm
yet including a potential trip to south
korea before or after the japan trip not
quite yet um i will tell you that you
know of course the president talked
about how he looks forward to traveling
to tokyo into the spring including for
the quad meeting and hopefully we'll
have more to detail for all of you soon
go ahead thanks a lot jen uh i just
wanted to ask a few ukraine questions if
i may uh a clarification first uh your
list of web memory that you put up on
the screen at the beginning of briefing
you had 11 mi 17 helicopters generally
there are two versions of that
helicopter one's a transport uh version
the other one is an armed gunship which
version are you supplying to i'm happy
to get greater clarity from the
department of defense obviously because
of the earlier questions you noted it
was do they want them did they not want
them they were just added back in so
we'll see if there's more detail and
then on sanctions when i hear the
possibility of more sanctions being
brought against the russian government
perhaps individuals in russia
i'm i'm just a little confused that you
haven't thrown everything at russia
already what what's left and why haven't
you thrown everything at russia already
in terms of sanctions well there are
always there's always more that can be
done on the sanctions front additional
financial institutions there's always
secondary sanctions there's a range of
steps that can be taken um we have
already done to date as i noted a little
bit earlier the most significant and
crippling sanctions package that has
ever been done to a modern like a big
economy ever in history so uh there's
processes that you have to go through to
consider to evaluate the impact on the
global economy on our economy whether
steps and and the assessment of that and
that's ongoing for additional options
one final one on a no-fly zone
possibility of a no-fly zone being
imposed by nato
sometimes
spokes people like you jen you say all
options are on the table is that an
option that is ever going to be on the
table we have we have never conveyed
from our end that it should be on the
table
thank you thank you
i would like to ask you about the
first of all i know you've heard report
that you may be leaving soon how would
you like to be remembered as white house
press secretary
well one day i will not be here uh
either
to spend time with my kids or because
the president fires me hopefully not the
latter um at that point i'm sure i can
reflect on that
the wh
said to me at the press briefing that
the the way the west uh the world is
treating the crisis in ukraine and the
crisis in yemen in ethiopia and
elsewhere seems to be different is it
wrong
i don't know more context of
refugees the way like you know ask you
many times why don't you grant the tps
to refugees from sure okay that's
helpful clarity on your question i
that's a that's a process that is
overseen by the department of homeland
security and an assessment is made
through that uh through of that process
so uh i don't have any updates for you
on that
but are you not supposed to lead the way
like these are people who are suffering
ethiopia is unstable tens of thousands
of people have been died and we
and we have spoken to that a number of
times from here from the state
department from the defense department
all i'm conveying to you is that there
are processes that happen through the
interagency and i don't have an update
on the status of tps designation thanks
everyone so much